Today we will try and understand
different religions in the right
perspective by trying to understand what
the scriptures of that religion have to
speak about almighty God.
First we'll discuss and try to
understand Hinduism in the right
perspective by trying to understand the
concept of God in Hinduism. If you ask a
common Hindu how many gods does he
believe in? Some will say three. Some
will say 33, some will say 100 gods,
some will say thousand, some will say 33
crores, 330 million gods.
But if you ask a learned Hindu
who is wellvered with the scripture, he
will tell you that Hindus should believe
and worship only one God.
But the common Hindu, he believes in a
philosophy known as pantheism.
The common Hindu says everything is God.
The tree is God. The sun is God. The
moon is God. The monkey is God. The
snake is God. The human being is God.
What we Muslims they say everything is
God's.
G O D with an apostrophe. S. We Muslims
they say everything belongs to God. The
tree belongs to God. The sun belongs to
God. The moon belongs to God. The snake
belongs to God. The monkey belongs to
God. The human belongs to God. So the
major difference between the Muslims and
the Hindus is the common Hindus says
everything is God. We Muslims they say
everything is God's go O D with an
apostrophe s. So the major difference is
only the apostrophes.
If we can solve this difference of
apostrophes
the Hindus and the Muslims will be
united.
How do we do it?
Allah says in 3:64
come to common terms as within which is
the first term Allahill
that we worship none but one Allah.
When we read the Hindu scriptures we
know the Hindu scriptures are divided
into two broad categories. The shri and
the smruti. Shri means those scriptures
of Hinduism which they believe is from
almighty god and smiti are those which
they believe are written by human
beings. So the highest amongst all the
Hindu scriptures in the shy are the
veedas. Then you have the upanishads.
In thei those scriptures were judged by
human being. You have many. You have the
puranas. You have the itas, the raman,
the mahabharat. And the most commonly
read Hindu scripture is the Bhagat Gita.
It's mentioned in the Bhagat Gita
chapter number 7 verse number 20. All
those whose intelligence has been stolen
by material desires, they worship
demigods. Here Bhagat Gita is saying in
chapter number 7 verse number 20 the
materialistic people they worship
demigods they worship false gods they do
idol worship when we read the opanishads
it's mentioned in the chandogaishad
chapter number six section number two
verse number one
it's a Sanskrit quotation which means
god is only one without a second
it's mentioned inad
chapter number six verse number nana
of that god he has no parents he has got
no lords almighty god has got no mother
he has got no father he has got no
superior
it's mentioned in sasarana chapter
number four verse number 19i
of that god there is no image
Pratima is a Sanskrit word which means
an image. It means a photograph. It
means a painting. It means a picture. It
means a portrait. It means a sculpture.
It means a statue. It means an idol.
So
chapter number 49 says
of that God there is no image, there is
no photograph, there is no picture,
there is no painting, there is no
portrait, there is no sculpture, there
is no idol, there is no statue. The
similar message is further repeated in
the Vedas. If you read the rig with
chapter number 32 verse number three it
says
of that god there is no pratima there is
no image there is no photograph there is
no picture there is no painting there is
no portrait there is no statue there is
no sculpture there is no idol it's
further mentioned in yaju chapter number
40 verse number 8 almighty god is
imageless and pure it's mentioned in
yajur chapter number 40 verse number 9
They and darkness
means entering they are entering
darkness those who worship the asamuti
the asamuti are natural things like fire
water air and the verse continues they
are entering more in darkness those who
worship the sambuti the created things
like table chair idols etc who says that
>> almighty god in the Hindu scripture
In yajuru chapter number 40 verse number
9 it further mentioned inaved book
number 20 him number 58 verse number
three d maha osu verily great is
almighty god and amongst the veeda the
most sacred adig
it's mentioned in rivid
book number two hymn number one there
are no less than 33 different attributes
given to almighty God in rigway book
number two him number one. One amongst
them is Brahma.
Brahma is the creator God.
If you translate creator
into Arabic it is khalik. So we Muslims
have got no objection to someone calls
almighty god as creator or khalik or
brahma. But if someone says Brahma is
almighty God who has got four heads and
on each head is a crown, we Muslims take
strong objection to it because you're
giving an image to almighty God. And
going against
chapter number four number 19, we says
of that God there is no image.
The other attribute given in riit book
number two him number one is Vishnu.
Vishnu is the sustainer. The cherisher.
The sustainer God. The cherisher God. If
you translate cherisher or sustainer
into Arabic, it is Ra. We Muslims have
got no objection. If someone says
Almighty God is Rab or sustainer or
cherisher or Vishnu. But if someone says
Vishnu is almighty God
who has got four hands and is traveling
on the sea on the bed of snakes or
traveling on a bird named as Garuda and
has four hands one of his right hand has
the chakra and the left hand has a
kunch. We Muslims take strong objection
to it because you're giving an image to
almighty god and going against jajuru ve
chapter number 32 to verse number three
we says
of that god there is no image further if
you read
book number 8 number one verse number
one
do not worship anyone but one god praise
him alone it's mentioned in rigway book
number six hymn number 45 verse number
praise him alone and no one else.
And the Brahma Sutra, the fundamental
creed of Hinduism is
There's only one God, not a second one.
Not at all. Not at all. Not in the least
bit. So if you read the Hindu
scriptures, you'll understand the
concept of God in Hinduism and
understand Hinduism in the correct
perspective, in the right perspective.